儒者であり 智者でありというテーマでいきます
パンディト 比丘アーナンダ
メーダーヴィ 比丘アーナンダ
さらに褒めるんです アーナンダには
ちょっと文章がおかしい
アーナンダはですか アーナンダは知者であるのです
理性があるのです 私の頭がいろいろ変わりますが
アーナンダには智慧がありと書いたでしょうと思いますね
やっぱり智慧がありダメですから
智者であるということが正しいんだからって
にがには消されてないんです
智者といえば 最終解脱に達した方という意味になります
普通 智者といえばもう解脱に達したという意味なんですけど
具体的にアーナンダ尊者の理性を語られるんですね
この場合はものすごい理性であるという意味になるんですね
それで具体的に説明します
ジャーナティアヤンカーロタタハガタンダッサナヤウパサンカミトンビククナン
アヤ
ンカーロビクニナンアヤンカーロウパサカーナンアヤンカーロウパシカーナンアヤンカーロランニョーラジャマハマッターナンティッティアーナントゥティッティサワカーナンティ
今比丘たちが釈尊に面会する時期
今比丘尼たちが釈尊に面会するべき時期
今 在家の男性たち 今在家の女性たち
釈尊に面会するべき時
それはしっかり知ってるんです
今 王大臣 他宗教の方々
人々釈尊にお会いするべき時期だと知っているんです
理性があったというのはそういうところなんです
具体的に アナンダ尊者両方知ってるんです
お釈迦様の調子も知っていて
人々の状況も知っていて
あんたブッダに会った方がいいんだけど
じゃあ会わせますから一緒に来いと
連れて行って会わせてあげる
だからお坊さんの方の修行の徳やら疑問が起きたりすると
これはこれはお釈迦様に聞いた方がいいんだ
で ちゃんとその時期で連れて行く
もしお釈迦様が私を一人にしてくださいと言われたら
もう会わせません 誰であっても
その時はもうケースがあります
お釈迦様が 2週間ぐらいね
一人になったと で その時がアナンダ尊者がガードして誰にも会えないようにしてあげるんです
その時もある人が来て
何か質問があって こういう質問をお釈迦様に聞きたいんだよと
阿難尊者はでは座ってくださいと自分で説法するんです
こういうことですと はい
帰ってくださいと 会わせてくれないんです
で そういうことで この見事にお釈迦様の気持ちも理解して
相手の気持ちも理解して
判断するんです だから問題が起きてないんですよ
阿難尊者はダマでしたとかね
私に会わせてくれませんでしたとか
一つも仕事ぶりには問題が起きてないんです
訴えはゼロ これってもうそうそう接する能力ですよ
あらゆる人がお釈迦様に会いますから
時々阿難尊者が人々にお釈迦様
あんたね お釈迦様に質問したらどうですか？とかね
そういうふうにわざわざ進んで言う場合もある
そうすると阿難尊者がそう言われたんだから
ではお釈迦様はこういう疑問がありますよと
その人は悟りに達します
そういうふうに ある人に強引に会わせたりする
ある人は断るし たとえ王様でも
そう簡単には阿難尊者通らないと釈迦様には会えないんです
まあそこはお釈迦様が智者であると
いわゆる理性 見事な判断能力があったという
そういうわけで この単純なスケジュール管理だけじゃないんですよ
阿難尊者は だから人面会だったら
現代だったらね 時間を見てスケジュール管理だけだからね
そんなものじゃないんです
釈尊の 1分でも大変大事な時間です
お釈迦様の1分というのは
とてもとても大事な時間です
一言葉だけでも人は真理を発見するんです
ですから 会いたかっ会いたがっている人がいても
その資格あるか否かは管理者の責任です
会うべきか そうでないかっていう
この判断はアーナンダ尊者がするんです
お釈迦様じゃないんです
だから アーナンダ尊者のおかげで
お釈迦様の時間は全く無駄にならなかったんです
だからすごい人類のためにすごいことを貢献して残すことができたんです
アーナンダ尊者がいなかったら
無駄な足がどれほど無駄な時間になるかというと
そうはならなかったんです
行き行くところで会う会う人に
悟りに達するまで指導することができたんです
両方の状況を把握して
釈尊に負担にならないように
人に批判されないように
その仕事を見事にこなしたんです
だから アーナンダ尊者がすごく頭が良くて智者であるということは
お釈迦様は最後にもう反抗するんです
これから涅槃に入りますからね
だからこれからも失敗起こるだろうという予測もないんですから
はい そこにアーナンダ尊者に四つの不思議がありましたと
で アーナンダ尊者がお釈迦様に会う
人に簡単に会わせないということは
お釈迦様はこの涅槃に入るためにサーリプッタ樹の下で横になっていた時
ある外道の人が話を聞いて
偉大なる人が釈尊がね
涅槃に入るんだと すごい人だと自分も聞いたことがありまして
どんな人かと どんな話する人かとちょっと聞きたかったんですね
もう時間ない 焦ってきたんです
慌てて来て もうお釈迦様も最後の最後の時間
まあお坊さんたちは周りにいるだけで
もう在家の人々やら王家の人々やら
もう最後に挨拶して帰るんです
忙しくて大騒ぎ すごい大騒ぎというか
みんな興奮状態というかね
ものすごい大変な状況ですね
その時 この人が何でしたっけ？スバッダなんですね
いきなり私はお釈迦様に会いたいんだと
質問がありますと ただ
それはアーナンダ尊者の仕事なんですね
いくら悲しくていたっても
アーナンダ尊者が仕事はする
ただ 今日はダメですと
お釈迦様大変疲れていて
もうそろそろ涅槃に入るんだと
死にかけてるんですからね
死にかけて最後の息を止めようとしている人に質問されるって冗談じゃないんですね
ダメです だからそんなこと言ったって
私はそろそろ質問することができなくなるんだよと
いえ ダメですと でお互い随分ちょっと声が高くなって話し合っているんです
アーナンダ尊者お釈迦様のことをもうそんな時じゃないんだよと
あんた来なかったのはあなたのせいじゃないんですか？と
最後の最後のギリギリまで
なんだこれはと そんなに知りに来たかったら
もっと前に時間があったんじゃないんですか？いろいろ言ったでしょうね
それは私の推測ですけどね
どうせいい加減ではないかとかね
お釈迦様にその最後の瞬間でその言葉聞こえるんです
だから阿難尊者にどういうどういう話ですか？と言ったら
こんなうるさい野郎がというかね
この時間で来て質問したいと思って言うんだよ
あ そう じゃあ通してくださいと
で お釈迦様はやっぱりその人に会うんです
で 喋る能力はなかったでしょうね
体力もなかったでしょうね
でも 最後の瞬間でも自分の仏教を広げるという仕事をお釈迦様はなさるんです
その時 阿難尊者はもう面会禁止というね
すごい厳しい態度をとっていたんです
で 通してくださいと言ったら
まあお釈迦様 お釈迦様に言われたらもうはいはい
どうぞと で その人は質問するんですけど
お釈迦様は簡単に答えるんです
質問がくだらないんですよ
で 真理に達する人っていうのは仏教だけですか？と
悟りに達する人はと 今までお釈迦様はそんなことをおっしゃったこともないです
でお釈迦様はまあ随分簡単に答えるんです
あの四聖諦を発見する人は誰でも悟りに達しますよと
仏教だけという意味じゃなくて
四聖諦っていうのは真理ですから
真理を発見する人は誰でも悟りに達しますよと
しかしですね この第1の真理も
第2の真理も 第3の真理も
第4の真理も 人類の中で説かれているのは私だけですよと
ですから 第1の悟り 合格
悟った人も 第2の悟った人も
第3の悟りに達した人も
第3番目に達した人も
仏教の教えの中にいるんであって
外は一人も存在しませんのと
他宗教でははっきりと言っちゃったんです
他の教えは全部空っぽで無駄で意味がないんだよと
そこで本人の曖昧なところも消えちゃって
それならやっぱりそれは正しいでしょうとね
まあこれが知らなきゃ悟れないならば
それを知ってるのはブッダだけだったら
ブッダの中でしか悟れないってわかって
その人はじゃあ出家しますと
その場で出家決めて悟りに達するんです
それがお釈迦様の最後の弟子
はい お釈迦様の話もまだ続きます
あれは今喋ったのはちょっと雑談です
さらにお釈迦様は阿難尊者を褒めるんです
４つの不思議があるんだと
１ 比丘たちが阿難尊者に会っただけでも満足するんですよ
ああ 阿難尊者に会いました
見ましたと 阿難尊者を見ただけで
随分もうものすごく喜びを感じるんです
よかったよかったと もしも説法するならば大いに喜ぶ
もし阿難尊者の話でも聞くことができたら
もう話にならないほど喜ぶんです
なんて楽しい幸福なことかと
それで阿難尊者が説法して終わるでしょうに
終わって終わった瞬間でも
沈黙に入る時も 皆もっと聞きたいという気持ちでいるんです
もっといくらもっと喋ったらもっと聞きたいんだと
いう気持ちになるんで
これ比丘たちが で 同じこと比丘尼たちにも
在家の信者さんも 男性の女性の信者さんはみんな同じであると
これは転輪王の特色と同じです
だから阿難尊者は見て飽きない
話を聞いて飽きないという
誰に？誰にでも同じです
すごい人格ですよ それで転輪王っていうのは仏教の理想的な王で
地球を全て支配する 法によって戦争しないで
人殺ししないで制覇する
理想的な王なんです だから人間の中で最高たる人間なんです
その人間にある特色があって
これ一つなの この 4つもなければ転輪王になりません
いくら見ても飽きない
いくら話を聞いても飽きない
人格でなければ転輪王にならないということで
同じ性格が阿難尊者にもありましたと
だからここでのお釈迦様は
人間の中で最高のトップに入れておくんです
また事実でしょうし はい
それでテーマを変えて釈尊の従者たちという
ナーガサマール ナーギとウパワーナという
これ大体阿羅漢に達した方々なんですね
またスナッカッタという比丘
この人は後で還俗したんです
で 出家して このスナッカッタがね
どうしてもお釈迦様のそばにいるんですね
それでもそばにいるんだから
当然お釈迦様のお世話もする
お釈迦様は何でもかんでもね
まあ進んでやってくれるんだから
まあ何も言わない しかし
お釈迦様はいつでも旅でしょうに
歩いてるでしょうに この人も後ろから行く
どこかの邪教の人が見ると
ああ あれもすごいな あの人の修行はとかね
ああ この人もなかなか立派な修行をしているんだとか
何でもまあ憧れちゃうんですね
真理はっきりしている
イエスノーはっきりしているブッダとしてはね
こんなみっともない性格はね
あれもいいや これもあれもいいんじゃない？これもいいんじゃない？とかね
そういうもう無知がね
気に入らないんです だからお釈迦様はある人のところ通していくと
犬として生活しているんですね
修行ですよ 歩かない 歩く場合は犬と同じく四本で歩くと
座る時も大便小便する時も犬やってるようにやってて
食べる時も同じで だからそこに憧れたんだから
この人に名前 あだ名スナッカッタとつけたかもしれない可能性もあります
大体仏教はできるだけ個人のプライバシーを守るんですよ
ほとんどあだ名です 人々
歴史的な人物なんですけど
実名は使わない 使う場合はもう本当に立派な方々のことで
サーリプッタモクレンというのは実名で
実もまだちょっと違いますけど
それは母親の名前だからね
インドではだいたい母親の名前をつけるんですね
誰々かの息子という で
名前はあるんですね コーリとウパティッサと
ウパティッサっていうのはサーリプッタ尊者
コーリタっていうのはモクレン尊者
やっぱり実名は残ってます
で アーナンダさんはアーナンダさんで
ウパーリさんがウパーリさんで
みんなもう実名ですけど
他ほとんど偽名というか
で使っています 偽名で称する場合は何か問題点もないわけじゃないんです
だからおそらくスナッカッタっていうのは偽名だなと
なんで偽名かというと
何か偽名ですぐわかります
あの人が犬と生活しているのを見て
このスナッカさんがびっくりしちゃって
この人もおそらく解脱者じゃないんですかね
お釈迦様と言ったんです
そしたらお釈迦様はあんた何言うんですかと
こんなのは解脱の道だと思いますかと
この人は解脱に達してないだけではなくて
解脱とは何かをわからないんだと
善悪の判断さえもできない無知な人であると言ったら
まあお釈迦様はいつでも人の悪口ばっかりと
人を褒めないんだと 言ったら
お釈迦様はああそう じゃあ見てみなさいと
あと 1週間でこの人は死ぬんだよと
それも食食べ過ぎて 食べ過ぎて死ぬんだよと
死んだらなんとかの名前を言って
その地獄に落ちますよと
で 予言しちゃったんです
結構お釈迦様も気に入らなかったでしょう
この人のだらしない性格
その上お世話するんだから
身の回りの で 気に入るわけないんですよ
そこでこの人何やったかというと
お釈迦様は戻ってからさっさと来て
君知ってますか？釈尊があんたのことをこうやって予言したんだと
ったら その人はあの邪教の人がね
予言したって では 私さんの予言破ってみせますと
いて 断食を始めたんです
食べ過ぎて死ぬんだから
じゃあ断食しますと それで周りかなり人気あったと思いますよ
その方さんも感動しましたからね
あの犬ぶりには犬業に
で 信者さんは食べ物を持ってくる
犬として食べるんだからね
いろんなごちそうをませてくれるんです
食べないんですね で 信者さんが心配して毎日持ってくる
で 食べない ああ 修行の一環でしょうかなと思ったりして
やっぱりもう 7日目になってくると
これ大変やと いくらなんでも
このままでは死にますよと
我々の阿羅漢が ということで
楽ですよ こういう犬業をやっていると
信者さんにとっては だって喋れないでしょ？犬は
褒めるだけで十分です
お供えするだけで そういうからくり
インドで今もやってます
ハヌマンの猿の牛をやっている人がいるんです
だからまあインドで禁止ですからね
植民地になってから裸でいることはね
だからほんのちっちゃな何かで隠す体ちょこっと隠して
体中猿の猿のように模様を描いて
猿のもう全部描いてるんです
でもいるんです それだけ
それで周りお世話係がいて
もう神様として尊敬するんです
そこで人々は金を持って
いろんなお供え物を持ってきて拝むんです
拝んだら一言葉聞きたいんですよ
でも猿は喋るわけないでしょうに
しかし 猿も方法とか喉から音は出します
で この人もテレビで見たんですからね
それはもう NHK でね
ものの物珍しいんだから
全部撮ったんです それでこの人はこうやってなんとか喉からね
音を出すんです そうしたら
このお世話にいる人が
この仙人が今こういうことを言っているんだ
こういうことを言っているんだとか
自分をやりたい 言いたいことを言うんです
それに詐欺師がお世話するんで
お互い様 結構金儲かるんですよ
結構金儲かる 金取るんです
ですから 人間にとってはそういう猿業
犬業は楽だと思います
だって説法しませんだからね
お供え物をあげたら十分
だからこの信者さんたちも 7日目でもうあらゆるごちそうを作って
なかなか珍しいものとかね
作って持ってきたんです
結局はまあ この人の好物は何かと知っているし
その人は 1週間も食べてないし
なかなかいただかない
大変珍しいというかね
ごちそうでしょうし まあいいや
ちょっとだけ食べるぞと
ちょっとだけ食べるんですね
食欲があるとちょっとだけで終わらないんですね
また自分のごちそうに好物になってくると
結局は食べてしまっちゃったんです
だって何の心の制御もないし
ただ犬でいただけだからね
食べ死んじゃったんで
その人で消化できなくて
それで予言一つ当たったんだから
お釈迦様 この遺体を捨てる遺体捨て場も名前みたいだよ
この遺体はなんとか名前の捨て場
遺体捨て場に捨てますよと
これそれほど遠いところではなかったんです
信者さんがね あの釈尊釈迦のね
予言を破ってやるぞと遺体を運ぶんです
まあ気持ち悪い遺体だと思う
だって犬でいたんだからね
人間として生活したわけでもないし
なんとかして運ぶんです
運んで あの墓場には持っていかないんだぞと
これは通して別の墓場に持っていくぞと
しかし あの墓場のところに行ったら
みんなくったくた疲れちゃって一歩も動かないんです
遺体はものすごく重くなったんだそうで
これ以上一歩も動けないんだから
しょうがない 捨てましょうと
そちらに捨てちゃったんです
その方さんがすごく悔しかったんで
これで次から次へと予言が当たるんだから
でもしょうこないのは地獄に落ちたことなんですね
この愚か者が あの遺体のところに行って
釈迦さんがお前 私 ちょっと名前
地獄の名前忘れましたけどね
なんだらかんだら地獄に落ちると予言したんですけど
本当にあんた地獄に落ちちゃうんですか？と遺体に聞くんですよ
それでお釈迦様に言われたことだから
お釈迦様に対してはもうすごい
もう誰にも理解できない不可思議な能力っていうのは限りなくあります
ブッダの言葉は嘘にならないし
間違ってでも嘘やと言えることもできないんです
言ったらその人はその場破壊するんです
だから地獄に落ちたその人は
この質問されると答えなかったらブッダに逆らったことになるんで
地獄に至っても これはもうできないんです
人間だったらいくらか反抗できますけど
地獄からその霊が遺体に移っていきなり
私は今なんだらかんだら地獄に落ちて苦しんでますよでいて
ドクンとまた立ったんだと
それで全部予言が当たった
当たったということになったんです
なのにこの人は減速したんです
でも 比丘としては成功しませんね
お釈迦様に対してはいろいろそうやって半信半疑で疑い持っちゃうと
だからそういう人々は従者にはならんでしょうにね
またいたんです チュンバという沙弥なんですね
沙弥っていうのは年下でしょうね
もうやっぱり危ないでしょ
お釈迦様と それから下げた名義長老たちも
その時その時お世話をしたんです
結局は定職ではなく その時その時
周り誰かお釈迦様の面倒を見ただけの話ですね
しかし 釈尊の気に入らなかったのです
もう一つは この阿羅漢たちがお世話をすると
お釈迦様もかえって困るんです
向こうはもう師匠ということで偉大なるブッダだから一生懸命やりたいんだけど
こちらも阿羅漢でしょうに
完全たる聖者でしょうに
お釈迦様はいろいろ仕事をさせたくないんですね
仕事して悪いわけじゃないんだけど
水持ってこいとかは言いたくないんですね
で 敬語とかいろいろ使わなくちゃいけないんですね
聖者ですから だからそれっていうのはちょっと人間として面倒くさいんです
で お世話する人がお湯を持ってきて
これは熱すぎでしょうとかね
なんとか言いたいんですよ
お世話っていうのはそういうことなんです
せっかくお湯を持ってきたら
お湯欲しいって言ったら持ってきて
熱い もうちょっと熱くしてよとか
そういう風にわがまま言える間柄でなければ成り立ちません
それでもしかすると熱いお湯は良くない場合は
お世話する人はね あまり熱いのはダメですから
それ飲んでくださいと向こうも言うんです
お互いにそういうことをわがまま言う間柄はうまくいくんです
これ 相手が悟った聖者になってくるとできないんですね
あ ちょっと間違えた 悟りに達して年
いわゆるお釈迦様 歳歳の時
専属の従者を認定することになさったんです
お釈迦様は 別に私はもう年だと
もう誰かそばにいてほしいんだと
誰がずっと付きっきりで私の面倒を見てくれませんかと
ウパッハイカというのパーリ語の名前ね
ウパッハイカにならないのかとみんなに聞いた
聞いたんです そうすると一番先に出たのはサーリプッタ尊者なんですね
それでその時 これは注釈書から取ったところで
ある人は私の鉢を地面に置いて森に入った
ある人は私が歩きたかった道を嫌で別な道を歩んだ
それは前の従者たちがやったことなんですよ
前に名前出た どの人でしたっけ
このナーガサマーラという人がね
一緒に行くと綺麗な森がありまして
気に入ったんですね そしたらお釈迦様
これっていうのは美しい森
うん そうですねと 修行するにはとってもいい場所ですねと
まあというお釈迦様は
ですから 私はこれから修行します
お釈迦様 鉢を持ってください
そしたらお釈迦様が今やめなさい
私は今一人でいるんだよと
後で修行しなさいと 修行には後も前もないんだからと
言って鉢をお釈迦様もいただかないんですね
そのまま じゃあお釈迦様
私は修行に行きますからと言って
鉢を地面に置いて森に入ったんです
お釈迦様 鉢を持って一人で帰ったんです
この人が森に入って修行しようと思ったら修行できないんです
ものすごい妄想が出てきて
特に欲に絡んでる妄想が出てきて
頭がおかしくなっちゃったんです
そしたら本人がびっくりしちゃって
私は出家なのに 戒律を守ろうというね
約束しているのに なんでここまで余計な汚れた思考が来るんですかと
本人が自分の心わからない
結局森に惹かれたんで
惹かれたことが欲なんです
修行に惹かれたわけじゃないんです
あまりにも美しい森だから
そちらにいたかったんです
本人に読めない お釈迦様
それは読まれているんです
危険だと だから本当の弟子だったら
ブッダがやめなさいと言ったらやめるんです
人が 1 週間もご飯食べてない場合でも
ご飯をもらった時 お釈迦様
あんたご飯を置いておいて瞑想しなさいと言ったら
本当の仏弟子だったら
はい わかりましたとご飯を置いておいて修行にするんです
でお釈迦様の言葉はそれぐらいもう絶対的断言的なんです
それはもう真理なんです
逆らうものじゃないんです
こういう人々がいたんだからね
もう一人が一緒にいて
お釈迦様がどんな道がいいかなと
まあ私はこの道の方がいいんだと言ったら
もう一人 このお世話する
いえ この道がショートカット
なんて言いますか ん 近道でこちらできます
いえ 違う こちらに行きますよ
そうあんた お釈迦様 そんな長い道で行くなら私は行けた
私は向こうで会いますと
いて 本人が近道行っちゃったんです
向こうで会いますと これは実際としてはね
逆らったんだからね 近道か長い道かって関係ないで
お釈迦様をお世話することだから
お釈迦様のそばにいることでしょうに
誰よりも先にサーリプッタ尊者がお願いしたが
断られました お釈迦様が誰か従者になってくれませんか？と言ったら
先にサーリプッタ尊者がそれでお釈迦様
私がお釈迦様のお世話をやってあげますと言ったら
お釈迦様が黙っているんです
で 目連さん じゃあでは私が頼んでみますと
阿羅漢たちが次から次へと
買って出るんです お釈迦様はもうじっと待っているんです
徐々にすべての阿羅漢たちの願いをもう退けました
あんたダメと言わないんですよ
何も言わない 黙っていると
アーナンダ尊者だけ黙っているんです
そちらにアーナンダ尊者もいたんだけど
全然出てきません では私がやりますと言わないんです
そうすると みんなお坊さんたちがもう阿羅漢たちが出て
お釈迦様は何も言わなかったんだから
一人しか残ってないんですね
そしたらアーナンダ尊者に
お願いしてみるように言われたんです
もうお釈迦様 従者が必要でしょうし
だからあなた 我々断られたんだから
あなたお願いしたらどうですかと言ったら
アーナンダ尊者が断るんです
アーナンダ尊者っていうのは
自分のお世話をするために資格のある
のは誰かと お釈迦様自身でご存知でしょうと
釈尊がその人を選ぶのではないかと
私は断りますよと ご自分のお世話だからね
ご自分に誰が気に入っているかとお釈迦様自身知ってるでしょうにと
だからご自分で好きな人を選ぶでしょう
私はお願いしませんよと
と言うんです アーナンダがこれから私の従者になると
お釈迦様がその時認定したんです
私は断りますと言うと
お釈迦様は何のことなく
これから私の従者としてアーナンダが仕事をしますと
いきなり結果発表するんです
合格発表 それっておかしいですかね
あれほど完璧に仕事をできる能力があったのに
買って出ません どうですか？我々の俗世間は
大体買って出る人には能力がないということなんです
私はそれに認定してくださいと言うと
とんでもない人なんです
文字も読めないとかね
だから能力ある人っていうのはちょっと態度でかいんですよ
で これは失礼な言葉かもしれませんだけど
私は政治に絡んだ話はただ冗談のために呼んであって目的はありません
で 小沢さんと福田さんがね
福田さんがかなり頭がいいんです
小沢さんを罠にかけたんです
で 政治できませんだからね
国会で だからしっかりとこの人の協力がないとうまくいかないんだからといって
よく話し合って 一緒に頑張りましょうということで
小沢さんがずるずると
やっぱり国の総理でしょうと
こんなに丁寧に頼むということは
国のためではないかと
自分の仕事をしっかりやりたいんだから
そこはまあ政治家であって
紳士であってね もう協力しませんというのと情けない
と協力することに心が変わっちゃったんですね
変わって自分の党に戻ってきたら
大騒ぎ 何するのか あなたはと
まんまと乗せられたんではないかと
ということは 首謀党首としては良くないことやったと
ただ すぐ瞬時に彼がじゃあ党首辞めますと
だってすごい人格なんです
失敗したんだから じゃあ辞めますと
私は大変迷惑をかけましたと
何の言い訳も何もないんで
私はかっこいいと思ったんですよ
その時は それで話していて
また 1 日以内でまた党首になると
マスコミがぐちゃぐちゃ悪口を言うんです
私 すごいかっこいいやと
思ったんです で なぜかというと
党の側から見れば簡単にクビにしたんですけど
じゃあ他の適任見るかというといないんですね
だったら党の方がみんなそんなこと言わないで
お願いします お願いします
もう一度なんとかとかね
すごい苦労して強引にまたその場所立場を与えるんですよ
だからその仕事できるんですよ
だからガチャガチャ言われると
はい さようならという党首なんです
だから この適任か否かっていうことを決めることは
そういう一つポイントなんです
強引にお願いしなくちゃいけないんです
逃げられないようにハメておかないとダメな逃げるんです
それで私がやりたい 私がやりたいっていう場合は
能力ないに決まってるんです
やらせてください やらせてくださいと
本人がそれで喜んで その刺激で興奮してやりたいだけで
そんなやりたいんだからって欲張って
自分の幸福のために 刺激のためにやると仕事を失敗するんです
あーしちめんどくさい
もうどうしようもないし
やらなくちゃっていう感じでやる人々はしっかりやるんですよ
客観的に物事を見て だから
このアナンド尊者の認定の場合は
そのエピソードで 我々には世間ではいろんな仕事にいろんな人を頼まなくちゃいけないんですよ
世間ではそういうことでしょうね
みんなそれぞれの立場をもらって仕事をしているんだから
だからその立場は自然に周りが与えてくれる人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
自分で願書を出して 裏で手を回したりして
お金をばらまいたりしてやるものじゃないんです
周りがお願いしますから
この仕事をやってくださいと
頼むならば もう完璧なもう人なんです
その仕事に資格がもう揃っているんです
そこで周りが自分にできないということを自覚しているんです
だから仕事を始めたらやらせてくれるんですよ
今難しいでしょ？いろんな仕事をするんだけど
周りがガチャガチャガチャガチャ横から口を挟むんだから
そうすると仕事できないんです
しっかりできる人にとっては
それであなだ尊者をお釈迦様がこれからアナンダが私の従者になるんだよと決めたんだから
お釈迦様から仕事をいただいたんです
アナンはもっとすごいんです
契約ないとダメですよと
はい やりますと 何の契約もなく
これではもうダメでしょうと
契約するんです アナンド尊者は冷静でした
釈尊に仕事を正しくこなすためには
条件を認めるように頼んだんです
従者として私が仕事するならば
もう私のやり方でやりますから
もう仕事をしっかりしたいんだからね
こういうこういう計画だよと
契約だよと 仕事の重大さはよく知っていたんです
ブッダのお世話だから
これ大変だと 他人に批判されされるなら
仕事を正しい行うと言えないんです
もしみじんでも一言葉でも言われたら
自分の仕事を完璧で完璧にならないことになるんだからね
また 自分の立場を守らなくてはならないんです
仕事をする人にもそれの権利があるんですね
だからそれを守らなくちゃいけないんです
だから会社でも 1 日中仕事でも明日もやりなさいと
例えば事故を何回も起きて人死んじゃったでしょ
運送会社なんかはね みんなもう徹夜して
10時間  12時間トラック運転して
会社に戻ったらもう他運転手がないんだから
君これも運んでください
また 12時間 ずっと運転したらそれで事故起こったりして
あれをで 断らないでしょ
それで契約曖昧というか
人間が曖昧というかね
人の命をあまり考えていないというか
どちらですかね そんなこと言ったら
この運送会社そのものを頼まないでしょうね
ちゃんとした契約があったら断ります
はい 条件に行きます まず禁止項目 4つあります
1 ご自分が布施としていただく衣は私に与えないこと
お釈迦様は偉大なる方だからね
もういろんな高価なインドではね
当時では服は特に高かったんですよ
手作りですからね 綿から作らなくちゃいかんだからね
今とは随分違います お釈迦様はもし王様からいろんな人からね
随分高価なものをもらったらね
そばにいる人にあげるのは当然でしょ
大体一緒に仕事を一緒に分けて食べたりするのと当たり前なんです
これは断ります 私にくれないでください
なんでくれないでくれるとき断ればいいでしょ
それはブッダに対して失礼なんです
これもらいなさいというと
もらうしかないんです
いやですよとは仏教とは言いません
だから最初からくれないでください
お釈迦様にはそれ禁止
アナンド僧侶がボロ衣を着てお釈迦様のところにとってもピカピカの新しい衣があってもあげることはできないんです
契約だから  2番目 ご自分がいただく食べ物や飲み物を私に勧めないこと
お釈迦様がいろいろ大変ごちそうをいただく可能性あります
アナン僧侶が托鉢に行ったら
もしかすると何も托鉢にいただかない場合もあります
お釈迦様がこっちをいっぱいごちそうあるんだからね
もうあんた食べて托鉢に行かなくていいといい
れるでしょうに それは禁止です
お釈迦様に だからあの偉大なお釈迦様に禁止項目をつけるんです
3番目 釈尊が住む場所に住まわ住まわせないこと
一緒に同居でしたっけ？生活させないでくださいと
君 こちら寝てくださいと
これはダメですと 私は別室に別室に私のところにいるんだけど
それもそういう意味で
お釈迦様はいるところはどうせ立派になるし
まあ在家の方々はね そこは失踪にさせないし
で 場所はいくらでも作られるし
今もお釈迦様祇園精舎でいた場所がね
そのまま残ってるでしょうね
結構当時としてはかなり立派なところでしたからね
そういう まあまだ残ってますよ
アーナンダ尊者はもうそちらにはいない
4釈尊が受けお受けになった接待には私を呼ばないこと
ある人がお釈迦様にお釈迦様
明日家に来て食事をいただいてくださいと言ったら
お釈迦様はそれを受け取る
OK と それでお釈迦様がアーナンダ
明日はなんだらかんだら人の家に行きますから
一緒に行きましょうと
私はその人と約束しましたから
と これダメです 頼めないんだ
お釈迦様には一人で行くしかないんです
お釈迦様が受けた接待は
お釈迦様一人で行ってください
私には言うんじゃないと
最初に禁止 だから言われたら大変だからね
一緒に行きますと言ったらはいと一言で行くんですから
あの偉大なるブッダもそういう風に
もう偉そうに禁止項目を立てると認めるんです
それからお釈迦様は守るべき項目
自分には一つもつけてない
全部お釈迦様に条件をつけるんです
私が人から受けた接待にお釈迦様がお出でになること
随分失礼ですね アーナンダ尊者が誰か在家の方にね
明日アーナンダ尊者は家に来てくださいと言ったら
アーナンダ尊者はお釈迦様にお釈迦様
私に人を頼まれたんですけど
絶対お釈迦様は一緒に来てくださいと言うとお釈迦様は文句言わないで一緒に来てほしいんだと
私が地方から釈尊に会いに来る人々の面会を決めること
いろんなところからビクビクにウパーサカウパーシカという人々は王様やら来るんですけど
いくら遠くから来たんだからといって
みんな私を通さなくちゃあかんのと
私が会う会うべきかないか
私が決めますよと 私に疑問が生じたら
即座に釈尊に面会できること
私の場合はね 昼であろうが夜であろうが関係なく
聞きたい時は聞きますと
何でも聞けますよと するとお釈迦様は断ることなく返事しなくちゃいけないと
私がそばにいない時になさる説法をすべて繰り返し
私に私にも教えること
私もいる時は説法したら自分が覚えてますよ
私がいない時 どこか一人出かけてね
誰かに説法したらね 戻ってきたらまた私に繰り返して言わなくちゃいけないんだよ
ずいぶんもう失礼な これはわざと失礼に感じるように
そういう言葉で成り立ってますよ
仏教は これ大変です こんなもう並みじゃないんです
仏教の世界ってのはかなり微妙に物事を言う世界ですからね
なんであれほど偉大なるお釈迦様に条件勝手に条件つけて
私お釈迦様はこの条件を守るならば
私はこの条件を守る それ全然ない
自分だけで一方的に条件をつけたりして
それで失礼ではないかと
ではないんです その中にすごい深い意味があるんです
これでアナンダ尊者の条件が自動的に成り立っているんです
なんで面会はアナンダ尊者を通さなくちゃいけないんですよ
お釈迦様は偉大なる方だから
誰が喋ったっても偉大なる師匠でしょうに
お釈迦様の勝手でしょうに
しかし そうなってくると
どうやってお釈迦様の身の回りのお世話するんですかね
お釈迦様は疲れている
それでは仕事でしょうに
休ませてあげることは
で 人は好き勝手に入ると
アナンは仕事はできないんですよ
だから人々の管理と同時にお釈迦様の体の管理はやるやるためには
もう自分がその権力ないと
お釈迦様からいただかないとできないんだから
仕事をこなしたいだけなんです
この方は ここでなんでお釈迦様の接待に行かないのかというと
批判を受けます まああなたはね
そっち王様のところやら大事なところやらね
偉大なる金持ちのところへちょい行っていいですね
お釈迦様のそばにいて贅沢できてとか言われるんですよ
そこで人がお釈迦様に接待する気持ちだったら
お釈迦様には接待するんだけど
他の人にはしませんという気持ちだったらどうします？それであなんで尊者もこそこそと一緒に行ったら
まあしょうがない ブッダと一緒に来たんだからということになるんですね
だから周りから批判を受けながらこの仕事できるわけじゃない
だから絶対行かないという
だからお釈迦様のご飯もいただきません
衣もいただきません お釈迦様が休みになる部屋にもいないという
自分が自分の力で托鉢にして
自分に与えられたサンガが与えられた部屋に夜を休んで生活する
じゃあ文句あったら誰でもいいんだから行ってみなさいということなんです
それからなんで説法っていうのは
お釈迦様のそばにいる方だから
みんなお釈迦様ではなくて
あんたのそばにいたんだから
お釈迦様そんなこと話した？あれ本当？と聞くでしょうね
必ずアナンダ尊者に聞くんです
この間 お釈迦様はこうする国に行って
誰かさんに何か説法したって話
あれ本当？私知りませんと
そんなことを言ったけどわかりませんと
そんなこと言ったら立場がないでしょう
だからお釈迦様 誰にどんな説法
説法をなさろうか アナン尊者は全部知っていて
ああ いえ そんなことは言ってない
それは間違いだと 言ったのはこういう言葉だよと堂々と言えるんです
そうすると 側近でいることをしっかりしているんです
みんな あ これはアナンダ尊者に聞けば OK やと
間違いなしということになるんです
そういうわけで 仕事を見事に完璧にこなすための条件なんです
それは裏にあるんです
なんでわがまま放題で書いているのかというと
それは必要なんですよ
お釈迦体の押しはするんだから
わがまま言える間でないと成り立たないんです
それでそれから 24 年間もお互いいろいろ言うんですよ
一から四まで禁止 アーナンダ尊者
サクションが断る項目ですね
ん？アーナ なんか間違いですかね
アーナンダ尊者が断るんですね
これはパティケーパ ブッダがやってはいけないという
私は断りますと 四から八までシャックソンが従うべきシャックソンにお願いする項目ですね
チャッターローアーヤチャナ
だからチャッターローパティケーパ
チャッターローアーヤチャナという八つの項目で
条件で仕事が起きたんです
すごい現代的でしょ？何のことなく仕事に行くんじゃないんです
ちゃんと契約書を交わして仕事をするんです
日本でやっているかどうか分かりませんだけど
アメリカ式です 契約書にサインしてから仕事をするのです
するとお互いの自由が守られます
どんな強力巨大な会社であっても
契約書をサインしているんだから
間違ったらもう裁判かけます
お世話になることで何も見返りを期待しないことと
アーナンダ尊者が献身完璧に文字通りに献身
お世話する それで終わり
話は その代わりにこれ欲しい
全くなし 無報酬です 文字通り
お世話する人の義務を果たす果たせるような理由
というわけで 仕事は真面目にできて
完璧な奉仕で もう何も見返りを持たないでやるんだから
世界からは何の批判も受けませんし
受けませんでした えーと
ちょっと休憩にします
うん